foreign
about this I didn't get a chance earlier
when we listened to Marcy's question
Marcy from Prescott Arizona and so for
today's talk aboutable segment I have a
tweet thread from our good friend Dr
Nicole lapera she's the at the holistic
Psych on
Twitter and this is a Twitter thread
from her a tweet storm one might call it
and here's what she had to say and I'd
love to unpack this together
you're slowly leaving survival mode
here's what to expect
we enter survival mode for many reasons
we're overworked exhausted unable to
cope and disconnected from our own
bodies so we go through life on
autopilot inevitably one day we hit an
emotional Rock Bottom a point where we
just can't go on anymore with Life as we
know it this is the beginning of leaving
survival mode we start to wake up we
look at our relationships who we spend
time with our work and how it impacts
ourselves and the world what we want in
our life our True Values our childhood
impacts who we are today
at first it's overwhelming I know I
sobbed on my kitchen floor many times we
start to practice self-care establish
routines and sometimes for the first
time in our lives we set boundaries I
love that suddenly we don't fit into
society the dysfunction has become
crystal clear and we're no longer
willing to participate
our confidence builds we restore our
self-trust relationships start to shift
some relationships end we're making
space we're making room for new people
and new experiences in our lives sounds
like she's talking about minimalism
our nervous system is adapting our
thought patterns are shifting we have
glimmers of Hope of belonging and of
connection sometimes for the first time
in decades
instead of people pleasing we're
respecting ourselves we're making
choices in our own best interest instead
of people pleasing that's why I thought
it fit with Marcy's question really well
because you were talking earlier TK
about once you're free from pleasing all
the people you're free from needing all
the things needing the praise needing
the veneration needing the adulation she
goes on to say we are choosing ourselves
it's not an easy easy Journey
and it's worth it
who's on this journey
and
I found that many people who call into
our podcast or listen to the podcast
they are on some iteration of this
journey leaving survival mode because
you don't thrive in survival mode you
survive you make do with what you have
but also you begin to realize as she
illustrates here I've been living my
life on autopilot and I've never stopped
to look at my relationships who am I
spending time with
I don't look at my work how I contribute
creatively to the world I don't look at
what my values are
by the way we have a values worksheet
over at the minimalists.com V
and so many people tens of thousands of
people have just printed this out it's a
one-pager and you get to identify what
your values are
and for the longest time 30 something
years I never sat back and said what do
I actually value because the truth is
however I spend my 24 hours that's what
I value if I spend 16 hours playing
video games today okay fine if that's
what I truly value but is this actually
getting in the way of what I value
well she says it's it's overwhelming at
first
but then we start to practice self-care
establish routines
and sometimes for the first time in our
lives we've never set a boundary
and no of course when you start to
withdrawal from the normal template of
society you may not fit in as well
but I don't value fitting in anymore
either yeah I used to Value fitting in
there's a slide in American Psycho the
the film and also the book but where he
takes his headphones off Patrick Bateman
does and his wife's like what do you
actually want he just looks at her and
he goes I want to fit in
what a terrible terrible value to have
because
what do you get out of that okay so you
fit in so what
and then ironically we also want to fit
in but then what else do we want we want
to stand out and so I want to fit in but
I also want to stand out and of course
that makes us
miserable and we lose confidence we
don't trust ourselves and our
relationships
aren't the relationships we actually
want in our lives and so when she says
our relationships start to shift some
relationships end that's just a natural
part of maturing of beginning to not fit
in right of not people pleasing that's
why I thought it was so perfect for
Marcy's question because when she says
well
instead of people pleasing we respect
ourselves because people pleasing
at your own expense means you're not
respecting yourself yeah
fitting in
imagine if I'm standing outside
I'm waiting for a ride
and a random car pulls up
and the passenger door swings open and
someone from inside the car says hop in
and I look in the car to see if I
recognize anybody and I see like 10
people packed into this car and I look
confused and the person says hop in fit
in
my question is going to be who the hell
are you and where are you going
what am I fitting into we strive so hard
to fit in but what group are you trying
to fit into who the hell are these
people and where are they going to take
you fitting in is not an intrinsic good
are you fitting into a prison
or are you trying to fight your way into
a paradise what are you fitting into and
what is that going to do to your life
but one of the hardest things about life
man is sometimes our hero's journey
leads us through places and spaces that
simply require us to be a loser or an
irresponsible person yes or an immature
person
in the eyes of other people because
there are so many unquestioned cultural
orthodoxies Stories We Tell ourselves
about what we have to do what we have to
participate in games that we have to
play in order to not be destroyed in
order to not burn Bridges well everybody
participates in the gift grab
Everybody Plays golf with the CEO
everybody gives up their weekends for
this or that and who wants to be
abnormal in the eyes of those people
but the question you got to ask yourself
is do you want to spend your life
chasing around
concepts of happiness and success that
you don't even believe in
do you want to spend all of your energy
being normal in the eyes of people that
never seem free to you or do you want to
be free according to what you think what
you feel and what you believe
you know you said a little bit ago how
whatever you choose to do with your time
that's what you value and so if you
spend all your day playing video games
that's what you value I think one layer
to that is it's either what we value or
it might be a case of memetic Desire or
it might be a case that I have
internalized a certain set of cultural
values that I've never questioned and
I'm chasing after ideals and values but
I never stopped to consider that's right
you know did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalists
private podcasts available exclusively
on patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free